donc
la majorité des jeux viennent d'amérique, d'
europe et du japon, nous connaissons leurs cultures,
nous savons à quoi nous attendre d'autant qu'il y
a encore de la
diversité dans la mesure où
nous, par exemple, en afrique du sud, avons
11 langues différentes,
c'est une chose chacune d'entre elles est liée
à un spécifique  une culture qui a des histoires différentes
jouant avec cela dans le développement de jeux comme
moyen de raconter une histoire cela vous permet
en fait d'obtenir beaucoup de contenu
qui est nouveau et qui n'a pas été pleinement exploité
nous avons beaucoup de ces éditeurs qui
viennent ici  ils veulent du contenu fabriqué en Afrique
et il y a donc une énorme opportunité maintenant, c'est en
quelque sorte le meilleur moment pour
créer des jeux ou essayer d'entrer dans l'
industrie du jeu parce que nous espérons que dans
les prochaines années, nous allons voir un
énorme  pic de croissance
[Musique]
vous